For one of these things to be in the return value, two things have to be true.
First, it has to actually match this regular expression.
Second, it has to be in this string.
So a1 does match this regular expression.
We're looking for things like a1, a2, b1, b2, c1, etc.
There's actually an a1 in this string. So, yes.
2b does not match this regular expression.
For this particular regular expression, the first letter always has to be a letter and not a digit.
This doesn't work out. b2 looks very promising.
It's one of the strings we would match, except that it's not actually found in our haystack string.
It can't be part of the return value.
cc doesn't match, because we're looking for things like a1, b1, c1
that have a digit in the second position. This is not a digit.
cc3 does not match because it's three characters long
and we're looking for strings that are two characters long.
44 doesn't match, because it doesn't start with a through z.
d4 looks very good. It's the sort of thing we would match from this regular expression,
but it's not actually in our haystack string.
Instead we have 44d.
The empty string--this was a bit of a ringer or distracter thrown in--
doesn't match our regular expression. It's too short.
It's zero characters long, and we're matching things that are two characters long.
But finally c3 matches our regular expression and it's present in the string, so yes.